[Music]
foreign
review the show where we break down a
year to bring you some of the most
notable moments in TV and film month by
month it's time to head back to the year
2015 and while that may not seem like
too long ago just think before 2015 we
had no idea what the return of the
Skywalker Saga would look like or that
some history themed Broadway show called
Hamilton was about to turn everyone you
know into a theater buff 2015 was a big
year for big budget movie franchises for
Amy Schumer for binging murder mystery
docu-series is like the Jinx and making
a murderer and for Game of Thrones with
its Cliffhanger ending involving one
possibly dead Jon Snow so put your
hotline bling on silent it was a popular
song then and get ready for your year in
review 2015 because here we go
[Music]
we're short 20. 20 dollars
that's fine
agreed amount or No Deal
you serious
you're saying I intentionally shorted
you
no
mistakes happen premiering on AMC in
February of 2015 was Better Call Saul
the spin-off and prequel to co-creator
Vince Gilligan's previous series The
wildly popular Breaking Bad this one
follows the making of Bob odenkirk's
lawyer character who would come to be
known as Saul Goodman a role that would
earn him five Emmy Noms over six seasons
this is Starlight Express I'm going to
give you a 9.6 for technique 0.0 for
choice of victim I'm a lawyer
furthermore does does this steaming
pilot scream payday to you huh they only
weigh that entire car is worth 500 bucks
is if there's a 300 hooker sitting in it
the sixth and final season wrapped up in
2022 and much like Saul Goodman's legal
record the series was very highly
decorated including writer's Guild
Critics Choice and SAG Awards to go with
a bunch of Emmys critics say Better Call
Saul is a quirky dark character study
that manages to stand on its own without
being overshadowed by the series that
spawned it I think I need to go I think
you need to eat something and that will
help no I think I need to go back
David sit down sit down sit back down
lie down on our mattress the sheets are
in the dryer but there's a rubber pad
also premiering in February was the
comedy series shit's creek it was
created by Father and Son Eugene and Dan
Levy who also starred as part of a rich
family that loses its fortune and
relocates to shit's creek a small town
they once purchased as a joke Catherine
O'Hara was the first choice to play The
Matriarch character Moira Rose but she
initially turned it down before
eventually agreeing to participate in
the pilot and thankfully continuing with
the series xiaomi David why do you want
this job I ran out of eye cream okay
you're not going to get this job you're
not going to get this job you know why
your attitude sucks okay and look at how
you're dressed what what is this
colostomy bag pants after various
networks suggested the title of the show
be changed during development the levees
found pages from a phone book to show
that [__] was in fact a real surname and
the rest is history sorry you'll have to
ask your parents what a phone book is
among its many accolades the series
received 15 prime time Emmy nominations
for its Sixth and final season and
became the first series to sweep all
seven major Comedy Awards critics say
the title is one of the best jokes of
shit's creek but performances from
Eugene Levy and Catherine O'Hara give
the writing a comedic boost is this your
brother
you have a brother
no
fine yes suppose the cat's out of the
bag I have a brother one brother all
those years together at the parks
department you never told us you had a
brother you worked at the parks
department tour's over and saying
goodbye to the TV landscape in February
of 2015 was the hit comedy Parks and
Recreation this Amy pohler-led
mockumentary about a Parks and Rec
Department helped launch the career of a
certain Star-Lord and made many others
household names like Adam Scott Aubry
Plaza and Nick Offerman we're also going
to try a pavlovian technique Ron is
holding Tammy's perfume girth oh
ah smells good oh again
Tammy oh how many times we're gonna do
this until the bottle is empty again
after struggling with ratings in the
shadow of the office the show ultimately
found plenty of its own success over
seven seasons and has gotten a second
win now thanks to Netflix critics say
Parks and Recreations closing chapter
definitely incorporates time skip gags
into the everyday bureaucracy upon e all
while delivering a moving farewell to a
cast of characters audiences have grown
to love like family
foreign
[Music]
speeding to theaters in April was
Furious 7 with the usual gang taking on
a new bad guy this time around played by
Jason Statham this marked Paul Walker's
final film appearance following his
death in November of 2013 with his
brothers serving as stand-ins to
complete Paul's remaining scenes hey man
listen I'm sorry to let y'all down okay
I'ma go ahead and stay up here nah
brother I'm sorry to let you down
[Applause]
the film was directed by James Wan and
written by Chris Morgan his fifth time
doing a screenplay for the franchise and
was one of the most expensive films ever
made at the time with an estimated
production budget around 250 million
dollars but that's okay because Furious
7 grossed over 1.5 billion dollars
worldwide making it the third highest
grossing film of 2015. now that's what I
call Fast Money critics say serving up a
fresh round of over-the-top Thrills
while adding unexpected dramatic heft
Furious 7 keeps the franchise moving in
more ways than one
you know what's in that cradle
power to make real change and that
terrifies you I wouldn't call it a
comfort
May of 2015 ushered in a new age as in
Avengers Age of Ultron directed by Joss
Whedon who also did 2012's The Avengers
This Time Around The Avengers assembled
to battle Ultron a technological Terror
aiming for humans Extinction that is
voiced by James Spader who Whedon said
was the first and only choice for the
part Age of Ultron introduced some
powerful newcomers to the franchise
including Elizabeth Olsen Scarlet witch
who would be a major force in the MCU
going forward she reportedly worked with
a dance choreographer to make her
movements more graceful for Action
sequences that little witch is messing
with your mind
you're stronger than her you're smarter
than her your Bruce spanner forever I
don't mention puny Banner
and the film did what Marvel movies do
become the second most expensive film
ever made at the time on its way to 1.4
billion box office dollars critics say
exuberant and eye-popping Avengers Age
of Ultron serves as an overstuffed but
mostly satisfying sequel reuniting its
predecessors unwieldy cast with a few
new additions and a worthy foe
all right
another action-packed flick that came in
May of 2015 was Mad Max Fury Road the
fourth in the franchise and the first
since 1985. George Miller who directed
the first three films was once again
behind the camera while Mel Gibson who
played Max in the original trilogy was
replaced by Tom Hardy this time around
it'll be a hard day
but I guarantee you that 160 days ride
that way
there's nothing but salt
it's that way you know we might be able
to
together
come across some kind of redemption the
film was conceived as one continuous
Chase and the entire thing was shot in
sequence to keep with the continuity of
that chase and Miller relied on mostly
practical effects to pull it off with
CGI being used sparingly the result was
a huge hit with fans and critics alike
keeping up the interest for more films
in the franchise including a furiosa
spin-off starring Charlize their own
critics say with exhilarating action and
a surprising amount of narrative Heff
Mad Max Fury Road brings George Miller's
post-apocalyptic franchise roaring
vigorously back to life
I just turned 30 Don
when
kept it a secret as I could
now I'm one of those women lying about
her age
I hate them
from Mad Max to Mad Men AMC surprise hit
drama series ended on May 17 2015 after
a seven season run with star Jon Hamm
leading the way this show followed
employees of a major New York
advertising firm from 1960 to 1970 for
trying the changing moods and social
traditions of the us at the time
what's her name
every copyrighter thinks of Shakespeare
something to Aspire to
I always envied that
before is reaching
all right because I mean you didn't have
to
in another lifetime might have been your
chauffeur series Creator Matthew weiner
wrote the first draft of the spec script
that would later become Mad Men while
working as a staff writer for the series
Becker in 2000. the series went on to
earn 16 Emmys and became the first cable
series to win Outstanding Drama Series
doing so in each of its first four
seasons critics say just in time to
rekindle viewers interests madman gets
back on track for one last season
revisiting its steady deliberate pace
and style on its way to a sure to be
compelling climax
[Music]
Lou
Stand Down
hey hey what did I just say
Delta I see you back up
okay
good
and in June of 2015 we saw the return of
another major movie franchise with
Jurassic world set 22 years after the
events of the original Jurassic Park and
taking place on the same fictional
island and it's there that we see for
the first time ever in the franchise
John Hammond's original Vision come to
life a fully functional and successful
theme park with cloned dinosaurs now
called Jurassic world but of course all
hell would eventually break loose
oh my God
man
[Music]
while stars like Kristen Stewart and
Harrison Ford were considered for the
leads it was ultimately Bryce Dallas
Howard and self-proclaimed Jurassic Park
fanatic Chris Pratt who ended up with
the roles BD Wong who plays scientist
Henry Wu is the only returning cast
member from any of the previous films
but the success of the installation did
open the door for other original cast
members to return for a film or two
critics say Jurassic world can't match
the original for sheer inventiveness and
impact but it works in its own right as
an entertaining and Visually dazzling
popcorn Thriller you know
hasn't had much remember
hey I saw a pizza place down the street
maybe we could try that pizza sounds
delicious pizza that's good
what the heck is that that's broccoli on
pizza that's it I'm done congratulations
San Francisco you've ruined Pizza also
opening in June of 2015 was the animated
film Inside Out featuring the voices of
stars like Amy Poehler Bill Hader Mindy
Kaling Diane Lane and Kyle McLaughlin
this heartfelt offering from Pixar
follows the internal emotions of an 11
year old Midwestern girl whose life is
turned upside down when her family moves
to San Francisco the film employed a
smaller than normal team of animators
and a psychologist in the study of
emotions and their reactions to facial
expressions was brought in to brief the
Pixar crew
oh
[Music]
what it's imaginary the formula worked
because this unique and refreshing
animated flick earned nearly 859 million
dollars worldwide as the seventh highest
grossing film of 2015 and it took home
the Oscar for best animated feature
critics say inventive gorgeously
animated and powerfully moving Inside
Out is another outstanding addition to
the Pixar library of modern animated
classics
[Music]
foreign
wow harder than I thought July of 2015
brought us another animated hit minions
a spin-off prequel and the third
installment in the Despicable Me
franchise the film features the voices
of Sandra Bullock Jon Hamm Michael
Keaton and Allison Janney with narration
by Jeffrey Rush as it tells the story of
how the minions came to serve area's
super villains over the years before
finding Gru
[Music]
Bello
minions pulled in over 1.1 billion
dollars worldwide as the fifth highest
grossing film of 2015 and it was
eventually followed by a sequel of its
own in 2022 minions the rise of GrooVe
critics say the minions brightly colored
brand of gibberish fueled Insanity
stretches to feature length in their
self-titled Despicable Me spin-off with
uneven but often hilarious results
is commonly known as crazy ants they're
lightning fast and can conduct
electricity which makes them useful to
fry out enemy Electronics those are not
so crazy
[Music]
that was a lot scarier a second ago also
making a big impact in July was the
teeny tiny Marvel hero Ant-Man in a film
directed by Peyton Reed who happily
stepped in at last minute to take over
after writer director Edgar Wright left
the project Paul Rudd stars as a master
Thief just released from prison and
recruited by a scientist played by
Michael Douglas who turns him into
Ant-Man with a suit that allows him to
shrink in size and gives him superhuman
strength what's going on down there Sam
I had a sensor trip but I'm not seeing
anything
wait a second abort Scott abort now it's
okay
I can see you he can see me
hi
I'm Scott did he just say hi I'm Scott
this marked the last film in the mcu's
phase two and it pulled in almost 520
million dollars worldwide before Paul
Rudd was cast Adrian Brody Joseph
Gordon-Levitt and Ewan McGregor were all
in the running for the lead role but
once red was finally cast he beefed up
so much that his suit had to be altered
during filming and speaking of altering
de-aging effects were used on a 70 year
old Michael Douglas for some flashback
scenes it's all about that technology
baby critics say led by a Charming
performance from Paul Rudd Ant-Man
offers Marvel Thrills on an
appropriately smaller scale albeit not
as smoothly as its most successful
predecessors hey LeBron sorry I'm gonna
interrupt did I leave my sunglasses here
I I don't know did you no I was sitting
oh here they are who did you just drive
40 minutes back here to look for your
sunglasses yeah of course you think I'm
gonna give Sunglass Hut another 30 for
these you crazy
hey how you doing okay your watch costs
more than my apartment oh this thing I
thought it was a gift we're watching
Downton abulator and calmly pulling into
theaters in July was the comedy film
train wreck directed by Judd Apatow and
written by Amy Schumer who also Stars
alongside Bill Hader Brie Larson John
Cena and LeBron James Schumer plays a
commitment phobic career woman who is
suddenly forced to reconsider a life of
promiscuity after she meets an actual
decent guy played by hater this is gonna
be great and I think she's cool and I
don't think I have to worry about that
you know right
oh
oh do you let me do that did I just
score on you yes you are my best LeBron
James but not really not really
you got man that was a good shot though
come on man I scored on LeBron James I'm
never playing basketball again lunch is
on you buddy where you going there
an earlier idea for the film involved
Schumer's character being a used car
saleswoman but the idea was mixed by her
and Apatow in favor of her being a
magazine writer and it seemed to work
because the film grossed nearly 141
million dollars at the worldwide box
office against a budget of 35 million
dollars and Schumer and hater were
nominated for best kiss at the MTV Movie
Awards but what more do you need critics
say Trainwreck drags commitment out of
all but the most rom-com phobic film
goers with sharp humor relatable
characters and hilarious work from Amy
Schumer
I'm on the plane open the door how'd you
get in the plane that did the plane I'm
behind the plane open the door
[Music]
open the door yeah yeah yeah yeah okay
okay continuing the awesome trend of big
movie franchises in 2015 was the fifth
installment in the Mission Impossible
film series Rogue nation which opened on
July 31st this time Tom Cruise's Ethan
Hunt and his team are on the run from
the CIA and find themselves in a war
against an international Black Ops
terrorist organization composed of Rogue
government agents from all over the
world
[Music]
thank you
the film was written and directed by
Christopher McCrory his first of at
least four mission impossible films he
had previously directed Jack Reacher
with Tom Cruise in 2012 and would also
write and produce top gun Maverick in
2022. ah they're working buds with 683
million dollars worldwide Rogue nation
became the eighth highest grossing film
of 2015 which makes Tom Cruise
performing death-defying stunts
involving a real Airbus flying at 5000
feet in the air totally worth it
critics say Mission Impossible Rogue
Nation continues the franchise's
thrilling Resurgence and proves that Tom
Cruise remains an action star without
equal
please
so yeah
I blew myself up
making contact in October of 2015 was
the Martian directed by Ridley Scott and
adapted from Andy Weir's 2011 novel of
the same name backed by a stellar
ensemble cast Matt Damon stars as an
astronaut forced a survive alone on Mars
after being left behind while NASA Works
to try and bring him back to Earth
filming took place over 70 days in
Budapest where 20 sets were built on one
of the largest sound stages in the world
on my way Commander
hey
Johansson what's my relative velocity to
Mark 5.2 meters per second copy
adjusting course
and with that both Andy Weir the author
and Ridley Scott strive to keep things
as realistic as possible seeking advice
from NASA and other experts the result
was a film that earned seven Oscar
nominations including best picture best
actor for Matt Damon and best adapted
screenplay critics say smart thrilling
and surprisingly funny the Martian
offers a faithful adaptation of the
best-selling book that brings out the
best in leading man Matt Damon and
director Ridley Scott
it's the resistance
[Music]
go straight at him don't let these thugs
scare you bro
[Music]
foreign
like a shiny present under the tree in
December was Star Wars the Force awakens
aka the first live-action Skywalker Saga
film in 10 years and the First with the
original cast in 32 years this time fans
were introduced to a new crop of good
guy fighters for the resistance and some
new nasty villains and said goodbye to
some old friends as well several
directors were reportedly considered
including David Fincher John Favreau and
Guillermo del Toro before the president
of lucasfilm Kathleen Kennedy hired JJ
Abrams for the job after a suggestion by
Steven Spielberg Gotta Love Hollywood
we need cover quick
[Applause]
the film broke various box office
records at the time and was the highest
grossing film of 2015 with a worldwide
Hall of over 2 billion dollars and for
that final sip of sweet blue milk
composer John Williams received his
fifth Oscar nomination for scoring this
film critics say packed with action and
populated by both familiar faces and
fresh blood the force awakens
successfully recalls the series's former
glory while injecting it with Renewed
Energy well there you have it our trip
back through 2015 a year that still
feels so close yet oh so very far away
what was your favorite or least favorite
moment of the Year an installment of one
of the many film franchises an animated
flick or perhaps having one last run
with Mad Men a truly unique show that
remains in a class of its own to this
day she's clearly I was a big fan anyway
thanks for checking out our year in
review for 2015. thanks for going on
that Journey with us we'll see you next
time